et avec nous pour cette eau vpl spéciale
ce soir alain marc bonsoir sénateurs les
indépendants de l'aveyron vice président
de la commission des lois est membre de
cette commission d' enquête sur la
sphère benalla muriel jourda bonsoir
sénatrice l ère du morbihan co
rapporteur de cette commission denquête
karine bégard bonsoir grand reporter au
service politique de france inter jean
yves le conte bonsoir sénateurs
socialistes des français établis hors de
france et membre de cette même
commission denquête et arnaud benedetti
bonsoir également spécialiste de la
communication politique professeur
associé en histoire de la communication
à l'université paris iv sorbonne
merci à tous les cinq d'être ici je
voudrais qu'on commence par un premier
tour de table relativement rapide si
c'est possible réel jourda quel bilan
vous tirez l'audition d'alexandre
benalla alors il est un peu tôt pour en
tirer un bilan néanmoins nous avons eu
une version qui ne soit pas que celle de
la presse sur les contradictions qui
pouvaient exister entre les déclarations
première de monsieur bédard est celle
qui avait été celle de monsieur strzoda
la semaine dernière donc le bilan est
déjà que nous avons un éclairage par les
différentes autres protagonistes
ce qui ne signifie pas que nous avons la
vérité encore mais nous avons un
éclairage par les différents
protagonistes qui était nécessaire à la
commission des lois est la marque
moi j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait une
différence avec la première édition du
mois du mois de septembre
j'ai trouvé qu'il était très à l'aise
mois de septembre beaucoup moins
aujourd'hui se réfugier en effectivement
derrière
l'instruction judiciaire qui est en
cours mais surtout dès le début on
sentait au mois de septembre il y avait
une certaine protection de la part
peut-être de la part de l'elysée
aujourd'hui les uns et les autres
s'attaque et monsieur strzoda a été
chaque fois la cible de ses flèches
alors qui dit vrai on ne pourra
peut-être pas à pas le savoir mais il ya
à la fois un changement de temps je
senti quand même moins à l'aise se
réfugie un souvent derrière à
l'instruction judiciaire
et puis attaquant ce coup-ci l'elysée ce
qui n'était pas le cas d'autres fois
c'est vrai qu'on se souvient qu'en
septembre
quelques membres du gouvernement qui
étaient montés au créneau pointant du
doigt le risque d'interférence avec la
justice là pour le coup est
effectivement les rapports ont un peu
changé à l'horrible aux comptes
oui tout à fait je pense que ça montre
que la csl la commission denquête la
commission des lois pousse un peu plus
loin que jusqu'à présent les fonctions
de commission d' enquête parlementaire
et c'est bien et d'ailleurs l'intérêt de
cette nouvelle salve d'audition c'est de
mettre en évidence les
dysfonctionnements de l'exécutif en la
matière que ce soit en termes de
passeport diplomatique
on ne peut pas les désactiver ce que
nous a dit le ministère de l'intérieur
la dernière fois alors qu'il ya eu des
des procédures en cours concernant
monsieur benalla et qu'il a été licencié
ressemble à quelqu'un de l'elysée lui
rendent ces passeports en lui expliquant
mora tu peux les utiliser
ça fait ça fait un peu désordre et et le
rôle autant la recherche de la vérité
ces deux rôles de la justice autant
pointer les dysfonctionnements de
l'exécutif c'est bien là qu'une
commission d' enquête parlementaire doit
se soucier son rôle est là très
clairement on s'aperçoit qu'elles sont
complémentaires et qu'on arrive à
pousser avec sedan ce dans ce cas là une
jurisprudence un peu différent de ce
qu'on avait jusqu'à présent terme de
deux commissions d'enquêté c'est
intéressant parce qu'il aura plus de
contrôle du parlement sur l'exécutif ci
après compte-tenu voilà de ce qui a été
fait de ce qu'a répété le président de
la commission des lois aujourd'hui et je
crois que c'est bon et ça montre aussi à
quel point le sénat est un est un
contre-pouvoir qui est utile et qui dont
les pouvoirs peut progresser ça ne
dépend que de lui négligence ou
protection d'élise et la question reste
sans réponse ce soir vous avez dit
philippe bas tout à l'heure karine
becker quelle est la vie de la
journaliste politique sur ce que j'ai vu
un changement de stratégie total de la
part de l'élection hervé dallage
parfaitement d'accord avec le sénateur
mark c'est à dire qu'en septembre il est
apparu volubile j'ai envie de dire
c'est à dire presque heureux c'est sans
doute excessif de ma part de dire ça et
puis surtout d'un jugement mais presque
re finalement d'être au coeur d'une
polémique
et ça c'est pas du tout le personnage
qu'on a vu aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on
avait un personnage très grave
exaspérés alors exaspéré ou jouant
l'exaspération en tout cas on a vu
quelqu'un de très graves qui
joue un peu sa vie et puis surtout qui
cherche à se défendre en fait qui se
rend compte alors probablement on va en
discuter mais qu'il était de lâcher par
l'elysée puisque vous en parliez à
l'instant et que désormais il est tout
seul pour réussir à s'en sortir donc on
a un changement de personnage un
changement de stratégie après pour
répondre à votre première question
résultats cette journée où cette
audition aujourd'hui aura servi à quoi
pour moi pas grand chose parce que on a
répondu à quasiment aucune question
c'est à dire ce qu'on veut savoir c'est
pourquoi ces fichus passeports sont à
niveau à nouveau en sa possession qui
lui a rendu qui a décidé de lui rendre
tout ça on le sait toujours pas et
finalement c'est le voilà c'est le coeur
de ces le coeur de la guerre passée
c'est le coeur du sujet du jour
notamment parce qu'elle a souvent refusé
de répondre
benedetti on a vu un aplomb royer s'est
abritée il s'est abrité derrière
l'instruction judiciaire pour éviter de
répondre à un certain nombre de
questions que lui posaient les sénateurs
mais entre temps si la situation évolue
et c'est parce que tout simplement la
logique du scandale ce qu'on appelle un
scandale en sciences politiques elle
s'est développée entre le mois de
septembre et aujourd'hui il ya eu des
faits nouveaux et c'est ce qui explique
vraisemblablement aussi le changement de
stratégie de d'alexandre benalla moi je
suis quand même frappé d'une chose en
effet il ya un changement de stratégie
je les trouvais globalement moins à
l'aise qu'ils ne l'étaient au mois de
septembre j'ai trouvé le président de la
commission beaucoup plus offensif encore
qu'ils ne l'avaient été au mois deux
mois deux mois de septembre
certainement agacé et ce qui est quand
même assez frappant c'est 'qui il y a
une stratégie qui vise à de la part
d'alexandre benalla a montré qu'il est
en conflit clairement avec une partie du
cabinet du président de la république
mais quand même il continue et ça c'est
très important à sanctuariser l'image du
président de la république c'est à dire
que finalement aujourd'hui il fait
porter la responsabilité
la situation dans laquelle il se
retrouve finalement à ses anciens
collègues pour aller vite du cabinet
mais il tient encore nettement à
préserver l'image et la personnalité du
président de la république ça c'est
quand même assez assez nette
alors on va ré écouter plusieurs
passages de cette audition évidemment
dans l'émission va commencer par celui
où alexandre men allah contredit très
clairement patrick strzoda lui même
auditionné la semaine dernière les
passeports et les avait bien laissé dans
son bureau quelqu'un l'elysée a redonné
sans qu'ils soient invalidés c'est l'une
des
majeur de cette audition et côté j'ai
restituer mais passeport les traits de
mon bureau
le badge d'accès à l'elysée et j'ai
récupéré un certain nombre d'autres
affaires comme un siège auto et un
chéquier une perte de clés également et
1 alors que je désire restituer dans le
courant du mois d'août 2010 huit essais
passeport mon été rendu à nouveau alors
que j'avais été contacté par un membre
de l'elysée un personnel salarié de
l'elysée début octobre 2018 je tiens
juste à vous dire que j'ai constaté que
ces passeports et on m'a fait savoir que
ces passeports n'étaient pas désactivé
sinon je n'aurais pas voyagé avec ses
passeports et je reconnais là une faute
de ma part un manque de discernement
peut-être une erreur sans doute gelé
reconnu devant la justice et je la
reconnais devant vous mais je ne pense
pas que ça mérite les proportions que
tout ça a pris depuis le début de cette
affaire
donc je vous le réaffirme solennellement
monsieur le président madame monsieur le
co-rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je ne vous ai pas menti le 19 septembre
lorsque je vous ai dit que mes passeport
était à l'elysée je ne vous ai pas menti
faute au manque de discernement une
erreur il dira plus tard dans les 10 ou
une connerie murray le jour dsk l'issue
de cette audition vous dites mais
quelqu'un nous a menti je crois
qu'effectivement nous avons deux
versions manifestement incompatibles
entre celle qui nous a été donnée par
monsieur strzoda et celle qui nous est
donnée par monsieur benalla aujourd'hui
sachant qu'on peut dire que lui même a
cherché à donner aujourd'hui une version
compatible avec celle qui nous avait
donné le 19 septembre avec un timing un
peu compliqué le 20 juillet ils quittent
l'élysée on sait que du 1er au 7 août il
a utilisé le passeport le 19 septembre
devant la commission
il nous dit ils doivent être dans mon
bureau à l'elysée et il les a réutilisé
début octobre
donc quoi qu'il arrive sa version doit
être compatible avec cette chronologie
nous at il menti ou pas nous n'avons pas
en l'état les moyens de le savoir mais
en tout cas probablement quelqu'un ne
nous a pas dit la vérité
on vous dit qu'on n'avons pas les moyens
de le savoir est ce qu'il faut lancer
procédure puisqu'il ya soupçon mensonges
de l'un des interlocuteurs de l'une des
personnes que vous avez auditionné
est-ce que vous pouvez lancer quelque
chose j'en ai vu le compte bien voir
plus clair le président de la commission
l'a rappelé à partir du moment où on ne
répond pas à des questions posées lors
de la commission denquête voilà une la
justice peut si la commission denquête
et le sénat décide de la saisir c'est
envisageable c'est une possibilité
condamner la personne qui a refusé de
répondre à des questions et très
clairement il a refusé de répondre à des
questions
il a refusé de répondre à des questions
et en particulier il a refusé de donner
une réponse qui qui permettrait de
crédibiliser sa version parce que tant
que vous ne dites pas qui à l'elysée
personnel salarié a rendu des passeports
finalement cette affirmation de vauréens
moi je rajouterais que je suis très
étonné de réponse que le ministre des
affaires étrangères et nous avons eu
aujourd'hui sur l'absence de notes
diplomatiques et d'être capable
d'arriver au tchad avec un passeport
diplomatique sans visa il ya pour moi
quelque part quelque chose que je ne
comprends pas quand on quand on connaît
le fonctionnement des passeports
diplomatiques on ne visite pas le tchad
il faut un visa quand on a un passeport
diplomatique sans notes diplomatiques et
la note diplomatique c'est un officiel
français qui la signe c'est 2016 des
phases de tanger qui le fait donc il y a
encore des choses qui ne sont pas du
tout expliqué mais l'audition ne nous a
pas permis d'avoir les clés qui permet
de crédibiliser cette cette version
d'alexandre d'ennahda il peut
effectivement fin nous pouvons décider
de le sénat pourra saisir la justice
et bien entendu les excuses de ne pas
participer à son auto à son à sa propre
incrimination c'est une cc c'est une
position valable mais ça affaiblit la
les affirmations finalement son
capacités de vérification qu'il nous a
faite au cours de cette audition vous
seriez pour la marque c'est la saisisse
la justice c'est moi je pense qu'on va
sans doute en débattre avec le président
de la commission des lois mais moi je
crois que s'il n'y avait
il suffirait à chaque fois que nous
menons une enquête dans le cadre d'une
commission denquête donc que des
personnes refusent de répondre pour que
plus rien ne se passe cela pour dire que
l'on ne sert pas à grand chose
or je crois que l'intérêt de cette
commission denquête c'est d'abord un
d'être en contre-pouvoir au niveau du
sénat c'est le conte mon collègue
lecomte l'a bien dit tout à l'heure mais
c'est de pouvoir aussi investiguer vert
dans des contrées que l'on ne veut que
personne ne pouvait jusqu'à présent
aborder et c'est ça l'intérêt et allez
un petit peu plus loin dans ses
investigations et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on voit qui bien qu'il y
à des contradictions entre ce que dit
peut être extrait da et ce que nous dit
alexandre alexandre bnl mais moi plus
que plus que cette affaire-là
je crois que enfin on ne peut encore
tirer les conclusions puisque ce sera
fait il me semble qu'il ya déjà
certaines grandes axes transactions
auxquelles on peut répondre là dessus
c'est à dire que tout du moins qui nous
serviront un petit peu de temps on
essaie quand un personnage de ce type
s'introduit dans le fonctionnement de la
de la république
cela veut dire déjà que qu'ils occupent
certaines fonctions cela signifie qu'on
ne fait pas trop confiance aux
institutions
or la leçon que l'on pourra tirer au
moins de ceux là c'est le fait que
lorsqu'on a des gens comme où j'espère
qu'ils sont l'élite des policiers
l'élite des gendarmes
eh bien je crois qu'il faut leur faire
entièrement confiance pour assurer
d'après la sécurité du président de la
république et ne pas s'en remettre à des
amitiés qui peuvent ensuite vous
conduire à faire des bêtises et pourquoi
pas à mettre en péril la sécurité du
président de la république
si un jour on apprend que ces gens-là
gentili a déçu qu'une société de
sécurité où jean sisto dernière fois et
muriel jourda vous seriez pour à titre
personnel que le cénacle commission
denquête saisisse la justice alors en
qualité de co rapporteurs je ne peux
guère mais que serait ce que pour
coralie théâtre que la commission
enquête faire à quelque chose il y à il
y a effectivement de dispositifs je
dirais à notre disposition d'abord comme
le disait mon collègue le compte si on
refuse de nous répondre
c'est passible de sanctions pénales et
si on estime qu on nous a menti on peut
également saisir le parquet c'est une
chose qui sera les deux éléments seront
évidemment à débattre si nous estimons
que à chaque fois
eh bien les éléments de l'infraction
sont constitués et alors que beaucoup
parlent d'une affaire d'état depuis des
mois que certains soupçonnent alexandre
benalla d'être très proche des manuels
macron de savoir des choses qui
pourraient compromettre l'elysée
alexandre benalla leur répond là aussi
c'est peut-être la première fois qu'il
va sur ce terrain écoutez je ne détient
aucun secret aucun secret sur qui que ce
soit je ne fais aucun chantage
on essaye d'expliquer un certain nombre
de dysfonctionnements de la part de
l'état un certain nombre de négligences
et d'erreurs et de fautes de ma part que
je reconnais devant vous que je reconnus
devant la justice et j'assume mes
responsabilités mais il faut pas en
déduire que tout ça au final est due à
un secret ou des secrets que je
détiendrait je ne détient aucun secret
j'avais une fonction clair que je vous
ai exposé au 19 septembre
j'ai rempli ma mission de manière claire
et je ne suis pas parti avec des secrets
sur qui que ce soit et j'essaye juste de
reprendre une vie normale et de me
refaire par mois même s'ils ont demandé
l'aide de personne
karine b car elle répond à beaucoup de
monde là alexandre men à la et peut-être
aussi aux journalistes qui pourrait
sous-entendre qu'il y à une affaire
d'état derrière tout cela qu'il cache
des choses qu'il ne dit pas parce qu'il
peut mettre quelqu'un en difficulté on
vous répond aussi il nous répond
complètement à nous et y répond je
trouve à cette impression que moi je
ressens depuis le départ avec lui c'est
que on a affaire un personnage un
personnage fantasque c'est presque un
personnage romanesque enfin je veux dire
c'est quelqu'un qui qui est content
c'est un peu ce que disent aux dépens
content d'être au coeur d'une polémique
qui porte son nom enfin je veux dire
il a touché du doigt plus que ça il a
protégé le président pendant plus d'une
année une année et demie ou quasiment
lorsqu'il ne dira pas tout arrêter de
fantasmer mais parce qu'en fait il l'a
créée il l'a suscité il a entretenu en
fait au mois de juillet à aucun moment
il a essayé de nous freiner
nous effectivement au mois de juillet
énormément de questions qui se posaient
alors faut se remettre aussi dans le
contexte c'était emmanuel macron
jusque-là marcher sur l'eau c'était
c'était ce président qui a été capable
de réformer la sncf alors qu' aucun
autre avant lui n'avait osé et on
pensait que tout le monde allait se
casser les dents sur cette affaire là
donc voilà on est on est face à un
président pour qui tout roule on a
l'impression que rien ne peut l'arrêter
et puis tout à coup les cette affaire
l'opposition s'engouffre évidemment on
se souvient de toutes ces images
s'engouffre sur enfin il ya une faille
et nous c'est tient finalement ce
président qui nous a promis
l'exemplarité ce président qui nous a
dit qu'il ne ferait pas de la politique
de la même façon ce président est
peut-être même avoir un bar blues qui
qu'il utilise pour des commandes des
oeuvres pas très fin des bases heures
donc tout a été réduit à aucun moment
n'a freiné ça en fait il était même j'ai
le sentiment peut-être que je me trompe
pas c'est de la psychologie mais dans la
politique trouve souvent beaucoup de
psychologie c'est un ressort qui est
toujours intéressant il est voilà pour
moi c'est un personnage romanesque et
tout est tombé aujourd'hui c'est pour ça
il ya un changement de stratégie et un
changement de personnes âgées je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui tout s'est effondré
oui les romanesques parce que aussi le
président de la république et romanesque
il faut ne jamais oublier je veux dire
que finalement bien quand même quand
même il faut jamais oublier que s'il y
avait suspicion et si la boîte à
fantasmes a été ouverte c'est parce que
tout simplement on a eu le sentiment que
l'elysée pendant des semaines et des
semaines ne coupez pas le cordon avec
benalla est la question qui se pose est
celle de savoir pourquoi finalement le 2
mai après les faits qui sont reprochés à
monsieur benalla celui ci n'a pas été
sanctionnée c'est quand même ça
aujourd'hui qui reste encore la cause
racine de toutes les questions que l'on
se pose mais ce qui est intéressant avec
les propos qu'il tient en est faussée
des propos qui confirment en pour
l'instant en tout cas qu'il continue à
préserver et c'est ça le plus important
l'image à sanctuariser l'image du
président de la république mais il ya
quelque chose de fondamental dans le
moment que l'on vit qui me paraît
absolument essentiel c'est on les câbles
dans un moment de réflexion
institutionnelle d'effervescence
politique et ce qui est extrêmement
important c'est en effet le rôle que
joue le sénat aujourd'hui dans la
tentative d'élucidation des mécanismes
qui ont conduit à ces dysfonctionnements
c'est que dans un système institutionnel
la france est un pays démocratique met
un pays démocratique finalement ne
respecte très peu les contre-pouvoirs
comparé à d'autres démocraties et pour
le coup en l'occurrence c'est vrai que
le sénat alors que des questions se
posent sur la légitimité parfois du
sénat elles sont même parfois dans la
lettre qu'il adresse aux français il y a
là une bataille politique et qui est
plus qu'une bataille de communication
qui tend quelque part a montré la
légitimité du sénat et la nécessité
médicale et le problème sur ce texte
c'est pour ça qu'on accuse parfois les
sénateurs et la commission denquête dans
la
trop fait construit aux états unis on
serait déjà dans une procédure qui
serait beaucoup plus avancé vers il faut
quand même savoir ce qui ce dont il
s'agit il s'agit quand même d'une
affaire qui touche au fonctionnement
même de l'état c'est une question
d'ordre public qui est posée monsieur
benalla collaborateurs du président de
la république est pris sur le fait en
train de faire le coup de poing contre
des manifestants donc ce n'est pas une
affaire bénigne qu'on le veuille ou non
c'est une affaire importante le monopole
de la violence physique légitime
c'est quelque chose qui relève de l'état
c'est quelque chose absolument essentiel
ce que finalement met en cause l'action
qui peut apparaître totalement insolite
de monsieur ménérat c'est bien ce
monopole là et c'est pour ça que ça a
choqué il
il a dit exactement ce qu'il fallait
pour relancer la machine à fantasmes à
prennent pas une ride
rappelons quand même le début si l'afer
a commencé c'est parce qu'il a
effectivement fait le coup de poing en
faisant en jouant aux policiers et après
on découvre six mois après qu'il a joué
à la cellule afrique de l'élysée sans
même que l'élysée prêtre soit au courant
en allant discuter comme le dit jean
piat soeur chiffon avec un certain
nombre de présidents dont je rappelle
quand même on a certains qui sont des
partenaires à ses fondamentaux de la
france en afrique et sur la sécurité du
sahel c'est assez incroyable de voir
qu'ils aient pu jouer ce rôle et ne nous
a rien dit de sa pige moi un petit jeu
malsain
il nourrit il nourrit lui même les
questions sur ces sujets là et sur ces
sujets il n'y rien il ne nous dit rien
sur sur sur doc il veut peut-être
simplement faire croire qu'ils jouent un
rôle mais finalement la manière dont
l'elysée a réagi pendant l'été à au
début de la sphère crédibilise voilà son
scénario
alors pardon mais je disais bien sûr je
pense que ce qui a crédibilisé beaucoup
l'idée qu'alexandre benalla avait un
rôle particulier et quelque chose
peut-être à cacher ou quelque chose
qu'il savait c'est d'abord la
disproportion je pense entre la sanction
et la façon dont les faits ont été
qualifiés par les représentants de
l'elysée mm apr s agissant des faits du
1er mai
et puis par le fait que après nous avoir
assuré que c'était quasiment une faute
détachable du service qui l'avait fait
c'est à dire que c'était certains
employés l'elysée mais ce qu'il avait
fait le premier mais n'avait rien à voir
avec ses fonctions à l'elysée
lorsque nous avons émis l'idée que nous
allions entendre alexandre benalla il ya
une montée au créneau de tout le
gouvernement jusqu'au président de la
république qui a pris son téléphone pour
appeler le président larcher
ce qui était je crois inédit que le
pouvoir qui est contrôlée appelle le
pouvoir de contrôle
bon donc ça a aussi alimenté le fait qu'
il se passait quelque chose qui dépasse
l enjeu même du fonctionnement de l'état
qui doit être contrôlé et clermont qui
alimentait savoie la chine aujourd'hui
effectivement alexandre benalla a tenu à
faire en sorte que les choses reprennent
la juste place qu'il voudrait leur
donner juste je vais bientôt mettre
d'ajouter je suis tout à fait d'accord
et en fait on est vraiment je reprends
cette image là on est à un moment où le
président marche sur l'eau ça dit rien
ne lui résiste donc il passe un coup de
fil et il dit mais non ça va pas se
passer comme ça en sachant il faut
rajouter que il le protège enfin il
donne le sentiment en tout cas de le
protéger beaucoup il c'est emmanuel
macron est ce le protéger et évidemment
il faut savoir que quand on suit
l'elysée de très près emmanuel macron
mais quelqu'un qui fonctionne avec très
peu de joueurs au tour de main très peu
il ya très peu de cercle d'ailleurs on
est tous très surpris de voir autant de
gens quitter l'elysée parce qu'on se
demande avec qui elle me donne le
maquereau on va par la suite fonctionné
et à partir du moment où il a donné sa
confiance
ça ne bouge plus aujourd'hui ils parlent
essentiellement alors au delà des gens
qui sont à l'elysée par exemple avec
richard ferrand et jacques mézard voilà
il parle pas à 50 personnes
voilà il ya quelques personnes en ce
moment sur les gilets jaunes qu'il
abreuve de notes qui lui font des
remontées terrain en qui il a
parfaitement confiance c'est-à-dire il
ya pas un éventail de gens énorme donc à
partir du moment où il a créé un lien de
confiance vise moi c'est manifestement
c'est le cas avec alexandre mennana il
avait décidé de ne pas de lâcher alors
on va continuer d'écouter quelques
passagers une séquence qui va longtemps
restée dans les esprits c'est cet
échange très tendu entre alexandre
benalla d'un côté et philippe bas jean
pierre sueur de l'autre l'ancien chargé
de mission à l'elysée a refusé on
voulait
à de multiples reprises de répondre aux
questions sur l'utilisation de ces
passeports diplomatiques
s'abritant effectivement derrière
l'information judiciaire en cours une
scène a été très marquante est dure plus
de 20 minutes
on vous l'a résumé en quelques secondes
regardez je suis désolé monsieur le
sénateur mais les conditions
d'attribution de détention et
d'obtention
c'est que de restitution de ces
passeports concerne l'information
judiciaire en cours et j'aurai des
questions donc deux juges d'instruction
qui sont saisis là dessus donc je ne
répondrai pas à ces questions devant
votre commission j'en suis désolé une
information judiciaire étant ouverte et
étant très respectueux des institutions
je répondrai aux questions des
magistrats instructeurs aujourd'hui la
justice s'intéresse à savoir comment
j'ai obtenu ces passeports
donc je vous réitère pour la quatrième
fois que je ne pourrais pas répondre à
cette question qui n'est pas une
question d'ordre administratives mais
d'ordre judiciaire
je tiens à vous dire que votre
interprétation est erroné et que
d'ailleurs vous n'avez pas opposé à une
commission d enquête parlementaire votre
propre interprétation par rapport à
celle que nous faisons car c'est notre
rôle d'interpréter
notre mandat est de définir le champ des
questions que nous avons à vous poser et
auxquelles vous pourriez répondre on a
quand même tous étaient frappés par ces
échanges assez tendu ses revenus à de
multiples reprises
est-ce qu'il a eue complètement tort de
ne pas vouloir répondre à la marque
oui moi je crois que c'est ce n'est pas
de la condescendance et de l'irritation
de sa part parce qu'il est en position
de faiblesse est en position de
faiblesse il se réfugie derrière à
l'instruction judiciaire et le fait
qu'il devra répondre de cela devant des
juges et je crois que ce n'est pas le
droit est un faux prétexte
le droit est complètement faux prétextes
cela se voit à quoi il nous semblait
cela aussi c'est la psychologie comédie
ma voisine mois voisine de gauche vous
savez quand on est un petit peu de
bouteille ça fait un moment que je fais
de la politique
on arrive quand même un petit peu
appréhender la façon dont s'expriment
les gens et ce qu'ils font et pour le
coup c'est vraiment une position de
défendre ce qu'il avoue sa surprise
agacé vous vous avez senti que du coup
il y avait même plus lieu dès que cette
audition n'avait plus lieu d'être
comment vous avez perçu les choses quand
il a commencé là c'était le début et
commencer à dire qu'il ne va pas
répondre non ça ne m'a pas spécialement
gacé me fait penser que le dise
on n'avait plus lieu d'être encore une
fois il était nécessaire que nous
l'entendions sur les contradictions qui
existait je pense qu'il a tort
effectivement le président bat laval a
beaucoup développé le pouvoir de la
commission d'enquêté complémentaires au
pouvoir judiciaire ils ne sont pas
opposés et nous pouvons parfaitement
enquêter ensemble l'un sur des fans
ministre hâtif l'autre sur des faits de
nature pénale
d'autant plus que monsieur pénale a
refusé de répondre à des questions qui
ne feront absolument pas l'objet d'une
tonne d'une enquête lorsqu'on lui
demande pourquoi il a quatre passeports
concomitamment ça ça n'est pas sujet à
infraction pénale c'est véritablement
une question à laquelle il pouvait
répondre et surtout fin il
il s'empare de cet argument quand ça
l'arrangé c'est à dire qu'il va
commencer son propos liminaire par nous
parler de faits dont nous ne sommes pas
saisis et dont nous avons même
interdiction de parler nous mêmes c'est
à dire des faits du 1er mai à la
contrescarpe et là il va développer sa
défense publique en réalité donc alors
que nous ne devrions pas parler de ça il
en parle parce qu'il y a intérêt et dès
qu'ils se sont un peu gênés
effectivement comme le dit alain marc
ils se réfugient derrière des principes
qu'il a décidé lui-même et qu'il n'a pas
d'ailleurs à imposer à notre que nous
faisons presque obstruction à votre
travail d' enquête tout à fait ben comme
on lui disait tout à l'heure
finale ne pas répondre à des questions
qui sont complètement qui sont au coeur
du fonctionnement de l'état comment
est-ce qu'on vous ait délivré le
passeport
sur quelle base sa relève
c'est une infraction que la commission
pourra relever alors que voilà de ne pas
répondre à ça alors on peut après on
voit pourquoi parce que si nous donnait
le nom de la personne qui lui a restitué
les choses serait beaucoup plus simple
donc on comprend pourquoi ils se
protègent mais vous avez des
informations de personnes qui auraient
pu je ne sais pas mais je pense que ce
que nous constatons c'est que deux
personnes qui étaient collaborateur du
président la république à six mois sont
aujourd'hui en contradiction absolue
donc là pour le coup faire émerger la
vérité
c'est du domaine de la justice et ça ils
le feront
par contre les dysfonctionnements qui
ont conduit à ce qu'ils disposent de
passeport diplomatique qui puisse
fonctionner après avoir été licencié de
l'elysée là pour le coup c'est
totalement c'est au coeur
de cette commission denquête de la même
manière que moi je suis assez frappé de
voir que au cours du quinquennat
précédent nous avons fait évoluer
certain nombre de lois en termes de
transparence de la vie politique avec la
mise en place de la haute autorité pour
la transparence de la vie politique avec
des obligations qui ont été renforcés
première loi du quinquennat macron sur
les obligations des membres des cabinets
ministériels
l'une des dernières lois du quinquennat
hollande sur les obligations
déontologiques des fonctionnaires et
c'est assez étonnant de voir que la
présidence de la république ignore et
n'appliquent pas les dispositions de ces
lois puisque les déclarations à la haute
autorité n'était pas faite et que la
manière dont les l'application de la loi
sur la déontologie des fonctionnaires se
fait à l'elysée semble assez
problématique
j'espère que ailleurs ça fonctionne
mieux et c'est aussi voilà le coeur du
sujet contrôlez regarder l'application
des lois c'est vraiment voilà le rôle de
la commission des lois d'une manière
générale et en l'occurrence la voix de
cette commission d' enquête qui met en
évidence des dysfonctionnements qui
interroge sur l'application de loi par
le parlement chef de l'état et ses
services à la marque c'était juste que
je trouve que cette audition avait une
vertu pédagogique pour les spectateurs
c'est de bien montrer ce que peut faire
jusqu'où peut aller le sénat et je crois
que philippe bas et ainsi que jean
pierre sueur ont été bien sûr ma
collègue muriel jourda qui est en face
moi ont été remarquées je le dis ils ont
été remarquables d'honneur
interrogations et ils ont bien montré
les limites entre ce qui relevait des
investigations de la commission d'
enquête du sénat et ce qui relevait du
jury du judiciaire
je crois que ça c'est très intéressant
je crois pour pour les spectateurs sur
sa stratégie
souvenez vous
il y à un précédent jérôme cahuzac
s'était retrouvé lui aussi devant une
commission denquête et s'était abrité
notamment
sutil était abritée derrière l' enquête
judiciaire en cours pour ne pas répondre
à un certain nombre de questions mais on
voit bien quelle est la stratégie de
l'ex andré d'allas c'est que il essaye
de gagner du temps parce qu'il sait
pertinemment qu'il est dans une position
de faiblesse
extrêmement importante et donc il joue
finalement les institutions contre les
institutions une institution contre une
institution ski quand même quelque part
aussi lui permet en tout cas de gagner
du temps qu'il est on a le sentiment
c'est en l'écoutant qui ne s'adresse pas
seulement aux sénateurs qu'il ya
d'autres messages qui sont envoyées et
ça c'est assez frappant
vraisemblablement un certain nombre
d'anciens de ses collaborateurs on voit
que il nous dit pas tout manifestement
que il jette un certain nombre de
signaux subliminaux
et c'est ce qui entretient encore
finalement le feuilleton qui à mon sens
n'est pas terminée parce que la
principale conclusion qu'on peut
aujourd'hui retenir de cette audition
c'est que en dépit de tout le feu n'est
pas éteint le feu n'est pas éteint parce
que il n'a pas répondu de manière
précise ok fallu déposer qu'un certain
nombre de contradictions sont en passe
sont apparus dont sont dans son
témoignage que il a donné une
information qui circulait dans la presse
mais qui l'a confirmé comme quoi les
passeport lui avait été quand même rendu
ça c'est important
au mois d'octobre donc il y à là quand
même un fils qui continue à courir le
feu malgré tout sous la cendre continua
à faire des dégâts et c'est ce qui
ressort en mon sens de cette audition au
delà il ya un grand sentiment de
confusion bien évidemment et surtout un
sentiment quelque part d'amateurisme au
niveau des services qui donnent le là
aussi une impression que
il y a à l'elysée des conflits entre les
hommes très nette et qu' on n'a pas su
gérer manifestement cette affaire sachez
vous dites plus qu'une affaire d'état
est ce que ce serait pas effectivement
tout simplement une affaire
d'amateurisme et c'est possible avec une
équipe de responsables politiques
d'hommes et de femmes qui sont arrivés
au politique relativement récemment
karine béguin
alors oui bien sûr souvenons nous qu'en
même que parmi les 20 sur les quatre
passeports dont on parle en permanence
il y en a un qui vient pas de cette
époxy qui vient de 2016
donc le précédent quinquennat sous
manuel valls qui n'a pas non plus été
demandée donc oui probablement qui à de
l'amateurisme sous ce quinquennat là
avec des gens qui n'ont pas eu
l'habitude ou très peu de travailler en
cabinet ministériel ou en tout cas
d'exercer les fonctions qui sont les
leurs aujourd'hui mais manifestement
quand même sous le précédent quinquennat
ça flottait aussi permettez-moi cette
expression là ça flottait aussi quand
même pas mal non moi je trouve que pour
rebondir sur ce que je viens d'entendre
alexandre bédat me donne le sentiment
aujourd'hui de ne plus avoir confiance
en personne
il donne le sentiment d'avoir été lâché
par l'elysée il essaie de garder son
lien avec les manades mac os que
j'allais vous dire c'est manuel mc oui
il est étayée il avait voilà il a dit
qu'il avait encore parfaitement
confiance en lui il essaie de garder ce
lien là mais moi j'ai été frappé au
moins deux ou trois fois
il rappelle il dit non mais attendez des
institutions c'est très bien mais la
justice je lui fais confiance et c'est
bien la dernière chose à laquelle j'ai
encore confiance parce que strzoda quand
il est venu vous parler la semaine
dernière et vous a annoncé alors que moi
même je ne le savais pas que j'allais
bientôt être mise en examen ou en tout
cas gardé à vue
on sent qu'il est il a plus confiance en
rien et cette impression là on l'avait
déjà à la fin du mois de décembre au
moment où la deuxième affaire banale va
éclater
il ya un certain nombre de journalistes
qui arrive à le joindre et il est
totalement à ondes
au départ il est survolté et à en donner
il est désabusé et il est fragilisé
affecté fin il est il est à terre il a
un genou à terre il ne sait pas comment
il va s'en sortir et ils soupçonnent à
un moment donné finit pas d'en savoir un
peu trop un peu plus vous avez remarqué
aussi ce moment où muriel jourda où ils
soupçonnent philippe bas d'en savoir un
peu trop sur la procédure il met presque
en cause son intégrité
oui effectivement
il lui a semblé déjà que monsieur
strzoda en savez beaucoup et comme
philippe bas répète à peu près ce qu'a
dit monsieur strzoda il inclut dans le
nombre de ceux qui en savent beaucoup
samassa m'a frappé également était
sincère pas sincère j'avoue que je ne
peux pas sonder les reins et les coeurs
mais j ai remarqué comme vous et un
moment de malaise alors on a aussi eu
l'impression effectivement que se jouer
un autre match dans cette audition un
match entre patrick strzoda directeur de
cabinet du président de la république
celui là même qui a donc semble-t-il
lâché alexandre benalla lors de son
audition au sénat la semaine dernière
celui là même qui a évoqué une
falsification de documents pour se
procurer un deuxième passeport
alexandre benalla lui a répondu à
plusieurs reprises et côté on à faire un
individu qui ne respectent pas les
obligations dont il a parfaitement
connaissance que ces obligations
figurent dans son contrat de travail ou
dans les documents qui lui sont remis il
ya eu je voulais déjà dit la dernière
fois un déferlement médiatique
un déchaînement politique avec la
construction d'un personnage d'un
individu comme l'a pu l'appeler
quelqu'un qui est venu devant vous très
récemment
alors que je constate et le mois de
septembre qu'il ne tarissait pas
d'éloges me concernant je peux affirmer
que monsieur benalla n'est jamais venu à
l'elysée après la date de son
licenciement
monsieur benalla vous êtes vous rendu à
l'elysée depuis que vous avez été
licencié
je ne répondrai pas à cette question sur
co-rapporteur tandonnet que ça
s'applique peut-être ou pas après avoir
quitté mes fonctions le directeur du
cabinet du président de république est
chargée essentiellement de gérer
l'agenda du président république
d'organiser ses déplacements de lui
préparer des dossiers sur linked contre
le terrorisme la sécurité des flux
migratoires des dossiers relatifs au
conseil des ministres
donc vous comprendrez que les
tribulations de monsieur benalla ne sont
pas ma priorité
je suis assez inquiet de voir qu'une
première fois devant votre commission le
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république
a évoqué que j'ai d'être convoquée dans
les toutes prochaines heures
ce qui pose quand même des questions sur
l'indépendance des institutions
on ne peut pas et surtout pas l'elysée
je vois pas pourquoi l'elysée serait
informé du déplacement d'un citoyen qui
voyage de par le monde avec son
passeport
nous avons été informés les déplacements
de monsieur biya la part des
interrogations de la presse
aux environs de bus 20 décembre du 20
décembre 2018
quelques jours avant que le président de
la république se rende au tchad
j'avais aucune obligation d'informer la
présidence de la république de mes
déplacements je les fais par courtoisie
vous l'avez compris vous a donc compilé
les réponses de lin de l'un et de
l'autre aujourd'hui avec alexandre bédat
là qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
j'enlève l'eau quand on voit qu'il est
un vrai match avait un ping pong y avait
presque un duel
oui mais monsieur strzoda est très
claire alors qu'alexandre benalla au
fait il nous dit j'ai informé l'elysée
dit nous dit pas qui ils répondent pas à
la question quand on lui pose la
question aussi sur qui lui a remis
répond pas donc en réalité il n'est pas
crédible
et quand il nous parle de respect des
institutions comme il nous l'a fait vous
nous avez montré deux fois cet extrait
et qu'après il se permet de remettre en
cause finalement l'indépendance de la
justice
quel que soit ce qu'on peut penser d'un
certain nombre de choses il faudrait
probable faire évoluer la dépendance et
la crédibilité de l'indépendance du
parquet c'est un sujet différent mais
enfin la manière dont il met en cause
l'indépendance de la justice dans cette
audition est assez décalé par rapport à
ce qui de près la manière dont ce qui du
tout quand il dit qu'il le respecte les
institutions et me dit qu'il a
effectivement la justice qui ne répondra
pas à nos questions donc bon voilà c'est
une stratégie de défense
en tout cas dans ses pompes on sent bien
que vous
validez beaucoup plus patrick c'est une
question de logique
c'est une question de logique il ne en
gros on a le statut sont quand même
vraiment différence du mois on a un
fonctionnaire qui s'est parfaitement
s'exprimer hécatombe sans doute
parfaitement préparé tout ça et qui
réussit à donner des choses très
factuelle sur lesquels effectivement on
peut s'accrocher
en face on a quand même quelqu'un qui
sans doute se pousse un peu du col mais
qui n'est rien oui sans méchanceté pour
lui du tout je suis d'accord mais
d'accueil ila il a aussi l'entrée il a
aussi montré dans ses auditions des
qualités de maîtrise de spécial de sang
froid chez qui sont quand même assez
étonnante et j'allais dire aussi que il
aurait pu répondre à un peu plus de
questions seraient crédibilité parce
qu'il nous a fait
donc à partir de ce moment là bien
évidemment voilà maintenant
adobe halal à la fin c'est vrai que ça
correspond aussi aux réponses qui nous a
fait qu'ils sont
moi j'ai du mal à assurer ce qui nous a
fait sur les ports d'armes sur sa selle
à son passage à l'office européen des
brevets à ce qu'il avait évoqué lors de
sa première audition
voilà j'essaie quand même important de
noter qu'on a quand même pas à faire à
deux personnages en termes de statut
semble alors en termes de statut c'est
différent bien entendu serait pas de la
même façon on raisonne pas de la même
façon
oui mais elle cherche des circonstances
atténuantes à l'excès dallas mais
pourquoi pas je trouve que c'est
flagrant aussi là dans le ping pong
même si j'ai été au mois de septembre
fasciné par la succession d'audition
entre deux donc de dextre bredalas et
derrière il y avait trace dont j'ai
perdu le prénom vincent kraz je veux
dire voilà on a affaire à deux hommes
qui sont dans
tout ce qui est sécurité sont des hommes
des terrains des hommes de terrain
voilà il ya quand même une différence de
niveau de langage qui était très
important donc on sent de la part
d'alexandre reynal à la volonté de
participer à ce cercle du pouvoir à se
pousser du col comme je disais tout à
l'heure après malgré tout il n'a pas la
formation tous ces gens là donc la
crainte assez bon endroit quand même un
métier derrière ils maîtrisaient quand
même très bien géré il a la qualité du
contrôle de soi d'expression ça c'est
pas ça moi je sais c'est pas sur ça que
je le jeu je porte l'appréciation de la
pression je la porte sur le fait qu'il
ne nous a pas apporté les réponses qui
aurait permis de crédibiliser ces
informer les informa les les
affirmations qui nous habite et oui moi
je trouve que patrick strzoda et
beaucoup plus factuel comme w dit et
donc c'est vrai qu'il apparaît comme un
étant plus crédible puisque à chaque
fois que nous avions des questions un
petit peu précises il se réfugier
derrière le fait que nous inquiétions
sur l'instruction judiciaire
et ça c'est une stratégie certes de
défense pourtant dans la première partie
naci propos liminaire il n'a eu de cesse
d'ailleurs dans une plaidoirie qui
finalement était pas si mal son registre
de langue à ce niveau là n'était pas
allaiter pas si mal que cela représente
peut être un avocat qui se défendent est
d'ailleurs lui-même
c'est un très bon orateur
par contre c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
de zones d'ombré ce qui rajoute à cela
vous nous avez aussi raison comme vous
dites qu ils se poussent du col etc
mais ce lien avec les pays d'afrique et
tout ça bon c'est vrai que ça laisse
toujours savez le la vieille idée de la
de la france avec ses râles et le
rapport avec les pays africains mais la
françafrique et c'est alors qu'on nous
parlait de l'ancien moins de 7 avril il
ya tout ça il se télescopent dans
l'esprit des l'esprit des gens et qui
n'est peut-être pas aujourd'hui très
sain et pour laquelle on comprend donc
que l'elysée aujourd'hui peut être lâche
lâche
parce qu'on n'a pas forcément emmanuel
macron justement muriel jourda et
ensuite arnaud benedetti sur ce
ping-pong avec patrick strzoda qu'est ce
que ça vous a inspiré cette séquence
oui enfin je les constate et comme
chacun sait est riche alors que
effectivement là où on avait deux hommes
qui étaient relativement unis dans les
premières auditions on a ici des
versions tellement incompatibles de même
fait que bien évidemment il son ton avec
un règlement de compte un presque
agressif il ce site serait l'autre
effectivement effectivement et en des
termes qui sont assez durs pour monsieur
strzoda puisqu'il parle de cet individu
et monsieur b dames on l'a vu l'instant
ne cite même pas monsieur strzoda
reniant quelqu'un que vous avez entendu
la semaine dernière
effectivement manifestement il ya un
enjeu qui n'est pas tout à fait celui de
la commission et parle de respect pour
les fonctions et pas forcément pour les
hommes un autre monde cette année il y
avait un bloc de défense indéniablement
au mois de septembre ce bloc de défense
n'existe plus aujourd'hui on voit que il
a sauté et qu' on est dans une séquence
de montée en tension entre au moins deux
personnes déjà le directeur de cabinet
et monsieur benalla donc ça en effet
c'est un fait tout à fait nouveau dans
l'évolution de la dynamique de la faire
moi quand même ce qui me frappe dans ces
images et dans le montage c'est que on a
rarement vu une telle publicisation une
telle publicité des dissensions
on sait qu'il ya des dissensions à
l'intérieur de l'appareil d'état est au
plus haut niveau dans les cabinets on
sait que ça existe mais sur la place
publique comme cela je crois que c'est
quand même un événement quasiment
nouveau et donc ça indique que
finalement on est en train de basculer
dans un autre système
aussi c'est à dire que la publicisation
de ce type d'affaires avec le rôle
certainement du sénat la montée en
puissance d'un certain nombre de contre
pouvoir fera qu'on ne pourra plus
traiter ce type de dossier comme par le
passé et ça c'est quand même quelque
chose qui me paraît assez mou mais
l'image sa porte a fait ça porte
atteinte en tout cas au
professionnalisme indéniablement ça
porte atteinte à l'image
parce que qu'est ce qui se dégage de
cela qu est ce que le téléspectateur
retire de ses échanges de
pau c'est quand même un niveau de
conflit que tu as lité au plus haut
niveau de l'état qui est quand même
assez incandescent et qui est sur la
place publique encore une fois qu'ils
aient montré qu'ils visible et ça c'est
extrêmement important et je pense qu'on
ait fait savoir voir des effets c'est à
dire que on ne pourra plus traiter ce
genre d'affaires pas ce que c'est mais
certainement pas le dernier scandale de
la république mal malheureusement auquel
nous assistons on peut penser que il y
en aura malheureusement d'autres
eh ben on ne pourra plus les gérer de la
même manière vraisemblablement quand
vous entendez que ça peut porter
atteinte à l'image du plus de l'elysée
du fonctionnement au plus haut niveau de
l'état est ce que ça vous fait regretter
peut-être la publicisation comme les
diano benedetti de cesser de porter
atteinte
le rôle de du parlement c'est de
contrôler l'action de l'exécutif et de
mettre le doigt sur ces
dysfonctionnements
même s'il ya des choses sur les
passeports bon on peut discuter ça aussi
c'est du district soir eric mais le fait
que ce soit public pour bâle a
abondamment demont met des choses en
évidence d'isa et voilà qu'on me le rôle
des commissions d enquête parlementaire
en france qui étaient souvent bien
disciplinée allez on la fait pas parce
que sans pied du ring
voilà une information judiciaire voilà
on évolue et ça permet de mettre les
choses différemment
j'avais dit en septembre qu'on avait eu
l'impression en particulier appart après
le coup de fil du président de la
république au président du sénat qu'on
avait l'impression qu'ils m'avaient
macron était le garde du corps de
monsieur ben ali à l'évidence il l'a
perdu son garde du corps et ça change
effectivement ça change la donne
mais je crois qu'en même temps on a posé
depuis le sénat a posé depuis l'été un
autre rôle pour les commissions d
enquête et que le contrôle du parlement
sur l'exécutif ne sera plus le même
demain qu'il l'était auparavant et ça je
crois que c'est utile au moment où
effectivement on évoque le rôle
finalement là une crise de la démocratie
représentative et où il faut bien
souligner le rôle du parlement et un
parlement utile c'est un parlement qui
vote les lois mais qui aussi fait en
sorte que son application soit contrôlée
on a constaté qu'un certain nombre de
lois votées
parfois l'initiative de l'exécutif
n'était pas appliquée par l'exécutif je
l'évoqué tout à l'heure en même temps
voilà quand il ya des dysfonctionnements
de cette nature c'est logique que
que le parlement s'en saisisse de
manière plus audacieuses qu'auparavant
jorda aucun doute aucun bémol sur le
fait que tout cela a été rendu public en
direct à la télévision et que ça puisse
potentiellement porter atteinte à
l'image de l'elysée de la présidence de
la république de nos institutions
j'entends cette analyse mais je crois
que précisément le rôle du sénat dans sa
commission denquête c'est de mettre le
doigt comme le dit mon collègue le
compte sur les dysfonctionnements pour
éviter qu'à l'avenir ils se reproduisent
dont je pense que ça plus pour effets
sur le long terme de consolider
l'institution et c'est le rôle du sénat
me semble-t-il n'ont pas de porter
atteinte à l'institution dizaine ce qui
n'a jamais été son but et encore moins
son rôle mais bien de la consolider pour
l'avenir en faisant des préconisations
pour que si difficultés et
dysfonctionnements il ya eu il ne se
reproduise pas à l'avenir
moi je crois que cette affaire a
finalement révèle que nos institutions
ne sont pas si mauvaise que cela
depuis cinquante-huit on n'arrête pas le
coup d'état permanent mais il ya eu
beaucoup de politiques qui voulaient
soit désormais faire la 6ème république
mais je crois que si aujourd'hui je
soutienne si le parlement oeuvrent à
faire la loi mais aussi et tu le feras
gêne sans doute à partir de cette
affaire a mais le faisait déjà mais
c'est l'acier plus mises en exergue le
contrôle de l'action publique
cela me semble aller vers ce que
souhaite finalement aujourd'hui les gens
qui sont dans la rue qui souhaitent un
peu plus de contrôle de l'action
publique
eh bien c'est ce vers quoi nous allons
et cette affaire me semble être ce
symbole là c'est peut-être pas une
affaire d'état mais au moins si cela
peut conforter nos institutions mais
faire en sorte que on retrouve le fait
que le parlement
une véritable utilité eh bien je crois
que ça aura été une chance et c'est
particulièrement important en ce moment
oui bien sûr il ya une envie une
appétence pour les pour la transparence
pour l'exigence de transparence qui est
énorme
et moi je me souviens du mois de juillet
vraiment
je sais simplement parce que je suis
journaliste politique on rentrait tous
les soirs pour suivre chaque audition
on vivait ça comme un comme un thriller
enfin je veux dire comme une série comme
une série policière à laquelle
aujourd'hui on est habitués donc un
espèce de mélange entre effectivement il
ya moi je pense que le sénat marque un
vrai point dans toutes ces auditions qui
ont été menées qu'on était bien mené
aujourd'hui franchement il fallait quand
même avoir beaucoup de sang froid face à
alexandre bédat là et on l'a vu ça a
parfaitement pas parfaitement fonctionné
non il n'a pas lâché
non mais on espérait mais en tout cas
voilà c'était doit très vite et l'onu on
a montré en fin de set de senna a montré
qu'il avait vraiment envie d'aller
jusqu'au bout donc les français étaient
en capacité de voir que il y avait envie
de faire de la transparence donc il ya
ça et puis après il ya quand même tous
ces médias aujourd'hui qui sont présents
qu'on peut critiquer par certains
aspects de temps en temps mais qui
malgré tout ça vous mettre en scène tout
ça aussi aujourd'hui c'est de plus en
plus suivi s'est vu et je pense que
c'est très important dans le contexte
dans lequel on est en ce moment on va
avoir un dernier extrait on a aussi vu
un alexandre benalla très marquée par la
faire c'est en tout cas ce qu'il a voulu
afficher des ses propos liminaires
ils dénoncent l'acharnement dont il fait
l'objet depuis des mois avec un seul
objectif selon lui en tout cas celui
d'attendre emmanuel macron en l'espace
de six mois
les choses ont bien changé elles ont
évolué plutôt négativement ce qui me
concerne et je dois vous le dire et le
reconnaître derrière la carapace il ya
un homme sa femme son fils qui avait un
mois et demi au moment du déclenchement
de de cette affaire une situation
professionnelle et personnelle assez
troublée qui ont fait que j'ai commis un
certain nombre d'erreurs des erreurs que
j'ai reconnu volontiers auprès de mes
proches près de mon entourage et que je
reconnais publiquement devant vous et je
les fais également devant la justice
alors on va le dire de manière peut-être
un peu triviale arnaud benedetti mais il
a voulu faire pleurer dans les
chaumières
oui alors ils essayent de ré humaniser
son personnage c'est un personnage en
effet qui depuis le début est considéré
comme un personnage sulfureux qui a été
arrogant
lorsqu'il était en fonction qui a été
considéré en tout cas comme arrogant
quand il était en fonction qui traîne
une mauvaise réputation comme on
pourrait le dire mais en même temps le
problème c'est la question de la
sincérité dans ce type de témoignage
qu'elle est la sincérité et quelle est
la vérité de monsieur benalla mais on
voit bien qu'il ya deux il ya deux
éléments dans sa stratégie de
communication
il ya une stratégie qui vise en effet à
essayer de décrire un personnage qui
n'est pas celui que l'on veut présenter
il l'avait déjà fait lors de la première
audition parce que souvenez vous des
conditions et du contexte de la première
audition il avait donné une interview
ils sont été prises
déjà au président est en bas et il avait
ensuite lorsqu'ils étaient venus
auditionner par la commission denquête
il avait essayé de faire amende
honorable en présentant un visage
respectable
donc il a déjà toujours été dans ce dans
ce don ce dans ce cheminement là dans ce
sillon là donc il joue sur un registre
psychologique c'est en effet d'essayer
d'attendrir le jury clairement en
rappelant sa situation personnelle en
disant que finalement aujourd'hui n'est
plus rien tu ils cherchent à vivre à
redon mesf actuellement c'est peut-être
un peu vrai aussi c'est certainement
vrai c'est certainement vrai mais il a
aussi ce quelque chose de fasciné par le
pouvoir
on sent que il y a dans sa façon d'être
en effet un petit côté narcissique quand
même aussi qui est rikiki qui ressort et
qui montre que c'est un personnage qui
est en effet assez satisfait de sa
situation aussi inconfortable soit elle
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
du mal à saisir quelle est la vérité d'
alexandre bédat là mais je ne suis pas
sûr que le registre aujourd'hui
psychologique qui utilise comme
ressource de communication soit un
registre suffisant pour quelque part le
dédouaner des responsabilités qui sont
les siennes à aucun moment il ne vous a
touché ou même attendre et je pose la
question aux sénateurs qui étaient
présents jeux
le compte pas vraiment vous êtes dur pas
vraiment parce que oui quand je vois ça
je vois qu'il essaie de nous faire
pleurer mais en même temps je me dis que
quelqu'un qui malgré ce qu'il a il
aurait ci l'avait fait en juillet là
effectivement il était venait de quitter
l'elysée
il était devant de finalement de jeter
en pâture
mais bon on constate quand même qu'il a
eu le culot de faire ce qu'il a fait en
allant voir un certain nombre de chefs
d'état africains 23 voyage c'est quand
même assez c'est quand même assez
incroyable de 2 il nous a répondu sur
rien ne nous a pas donné d'explication
sur la la la la la une les motivations
de ces voyages bon et puis après ils
nous donnent l'impression d'être comme
ça aux abois c'est on sait pas très
crédible touché par les la vie
bouleversée d'alexandre je peux entendre
qu humainement ce soit difficile pour
lui surtout que cette année ces jeunes
hommes on semble l'oublier il a 27 ans
donc je peux tout à fait entendre ça
maintenant la commission denquête elles
portent sur le fonctionnement de l'état
pas sur la sincérité des sentiments de
monsieur b l'ena d'où je n'en dirai pas
plus à la marque aussi moi je voulais on
a un petit peu de cantons les sénateurs
souvent du moins pour les sénateurs qui
sont un exercice aujourd'hui on est un
petit peu de bouteille politique donc on
est habitué à rencontrer des gens et
avoir ce qu'il faut effectivement on
pourrait se laisser attendrir là mais ce
n'est pas le cas je crois que les uns et
les autres nous sommes des gens qui
questionnent d'être dans la raison est
la raison aurait été pour monsieur
benalla aujourd'hui qui répondent à nos
questions et non pas qu'ils se réfugient
derrière des arguties juridiques et je
crois que ce fait là fait que ce qui
aurait pu nous attendrir au début est
finalement passé aux largement au second
plan avec tout ce qu'il a refusé
finalement de nous dire ensuite après ça
m'amuse entendre tout ça parce que
journalistique mans je ne peux pas
m'empêcher moi de penser à ce mois de
juillet c'était manuel macron qui nous
dit mais qu'il vienne me chercher
enfin je veux dire le mec il était
planquée derrière quand même bénin il
était pro ultra protégé quand même ils
viennent me chercher et après on en
cherche plus la vérité
exactement au d'emmanuel avait raison et
puis ensuite on a on a tout ce mois de
septembre vous l'avez rappelé plusieurs
fois mais il n'ya pas que le président
qui a appelé le président larcher c'est
moi je me souviens par exemple sur mon
antenne à france inter de nicole
belloubet la ministre la justice qui
vient nous expliquer quand même qui est
que ces auditions elle est ridicule
qu'il doit surtout pas s'y rende enfin
et d'autre un benjamin griveaux etc qui
prennent le relais
donc on a quand même un personnage ultra
protégée et puis enfin je veux dire
encore une fois psychologiques pour faut
juste accepter quand même que ce type la
deuxième affaire qui arrive au mois de
décembre qui est totalement lâché parce
qu'effectivement le pouvoir ne peut
absolument plus assumer on n'est plus
dans je réussis tout mais on est face à
des gilet jaune
on vient de connaître le 1er décembre le
8 décembre avec quand même des scènes
hallucinantes on a le sentiment d'un
état qui arrivent plus exactement à
tenir l'ordre dans son pays et qui est
complètement affolée et évidemment qu'on
peut plus tenir alexandre viala et je
trouve que le personnage qu'on voit là
aujourd'hui c'est ce personnage qui se
sont complètement abandonné et qui sait
pas gérer en fait et qui nous dit alors
sincérité ou pas ça je suis d'accord
avec vous on n'en sait rien mais qui
nous dit je suis quand même un homme
j'ai quand même une femme et j'ai en
plus un enfant de je sais pas comment je
vais gérer tout ça non mais c'est vrai
que cette affaire est sûre souligner
dans le contexte politique que l'on
traverse un certain nombre des
récriminations qui sont faites au
pouvoir c'est bien le problème
qu'est ce que c'est finalement la sphère
benalla au delà du problème d'ordre
public c'est aussi le problème des
privilèges
parce que ce qui a choqué aussi un
certain nombre de segments de l'opinion
c'est les privilèges
avery ou pas dont il aurait été le
bénéficiaire
donc si vous voulez dans un contexte où
il y a un doute quant à la parole
publique dans un contexte où il ya quand
même une remise en cause des
institutions tout ce qui peut apparaître
du ressort du privilège du ressort de
l'absence de transparence de du
caractère exorbitant dans un dans un
climat qui est quand même profondément
marqué par une revendication qu'il faut
bien appeler d'égalité il est évident
que la sphère benalla elle vient
sursaturé et surinfectée le climat
politique dans lequel nous nous trouvons
aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que ce
deuxième étape de la sphère benalla
tombe au plus mauvais au plus mauvais
moment pour le pouvoir et ce sera le mot
de la fin merci infiniment à tous les
cinq d'avoir participé à cette émission